こんにちははじめしゃちょーですそして
はじめしゃちょーでした1号ですはじめ
しゃちょーの手下2号ですそして
はじめしゃちょーのでした3号ですはじめ
しゃちょーでした4号ですはじめしゃ
ちょーのでした午後です
初めてのでした6号ですはじめしゃちょー
のでした7号ですはじめしゃちょーのでし
た8号ですはじめしゃちょーのでした9号
ですスクワットですお願いします
皆さんYouTuberって挨拶あると
思うんですよはい
スクワットもあるでしょそういう挨拶
みたいなはいちょっと見てみてもいいです
か
いきます
グループYouTuberとかってこう
挨拶いろんな人あるじゃないですか
もちろん一人でやってる人もいろんな挨拶
ありますよブンブンハローYouTube
とか
代名詞だあと誰かいたっけあと他にいくら
でもいるでしょうはい
それくらいですかね
[音楽]
ごきげんよう
誰か朝倉いろんな
[拍手]
挨拶あると思うしなんかねすごい長い挨拶
とか
独特な挨拶する人もいると思うんですけど
もえ今回ですねおそらく暫定
世界一ならYouTuberの挨拶考えて
きました
ギネス取りました
[拍手]
特段の偏見で考えて作らせていただいたの
を僕いつも1人で動画撮ってるんで
せっかくみんなくれたということでみんな
で俺の考えた挨拶完璧に言うまで終われ
まって
いただきます
どうも
レッツgotoheaveninthe
morningPartyGalaxy
バージョンアルファこうが
フェニックスインフィニティ
ドラゴニックスマスター
コングラッチェレーショニング
ダイナソーセンタービコーズ裏筋
クリニックはるか
けんご健介
合わせて全員合わせてお手で合わせて
いただきますカット
ラリーラリーとドリブルドリブル
パスカット行ってててて
レッツGO2ハウスって俺忘れとる
バキュンまあまあまあまたそう岡山が産ん
だ奇跡のブサイ人のこと不細工っていう
ナット巻きルールヌルあー興奮してきた
ようバギーンおいおいみんな静粛にここを
陛下がお見えたぞ
って紺色のまだあって
いいですどうも
レッツゴッドヘブンインザモーニング
パーティーギャラクシーバージョン
アネファコカンフェニックスインフィニティ
ドラゴニックスバスターこんがら
テレーションリングダイナソーセンター
ビルド裏筋クリニックはじめたよしデブ
はるかけんご健介
バキューンでニャンニャンネンドール俺
たち合わせて全員合わせてお手で合わせて
パンいただきますカット
ラディられるやつとドリブルドリブル
パスカット行っててててレッツgoto
羽田ハスって俺忘れとるバキュームだ
奇跡の不細工人のことブサイクっていう
納豆巻きヌルヌルああ興奮してきた
静粛にここを変化がおめえだとああ
日本国憲法の目を日本国民は正当に選挙さ
れた国会に起きる代表者を通じて行動し我
らの我々の子孫のために諸国民と評判に
よる成果とわかった国全土に渡って
コントラス先代は
確保する政府の行為によって再び戦争の
傘下が起こることのないようにすることを
決意しここに主催が国民に存じることを
宣言しこの憲法を確定するお前が言うん
カースコンデンあなたの心にズッキン
ばっきゅんドッキュンコンコンちゅ-こん
でるエスタブリッシュキノコ王国捨てれ
てってれってママミーアドンキーコングや
ないかよろしくお願いしますカット
ラリーらりらりやっといっつも
HIKAKINですね
途中シソ強めの入ってましたけど
戦争をしないことをこれ
全員言えるようになるわけではなく役割が
あってこれはだいたい均等に悪い感じに
なると思いますはいでもこれさ
想像してみばしんで決まった時めっちゃ
かっこいいよ
確かにね
色々ちょっとずつみんなで練習して綺麗に
バシッと決まったらこの動画終わりたいと
思います
行きましょう
決まらなかった場合とかは決まるまでやり
ます
喧嘩は無しでいこう
そうそうさっそくみんなでやっていき
ましょう
数のところがパキューしかないんですよ
若干調節させていただきますねその結果
[音楽]
から日本国憲法全部
地層全部俺だYouTubeって
テンポンの良さだと思うんで確かにここ
ずれるともう俺はアウトかなって思って
そこはそうですねみんなそれぞれのその
厄年1回読んでみますか1回読み合わせし
てみましょう
パキュン数バキューン
全員合わせて
合わせて
いただきます日本
国民は設定
ママ見やーい
HIKAKINです
それをもっとテンポよくだからちゃんと
リズム行くからになるようにはしてあるの
で
憲法以外はあと全員のとこ揃うかですね
そうですね確かにパソコン姉ちゃんの
ところとかは結構苦しい
呼びつ練習とこの合同練習とかをこう
全部っていうのはその前日とコーレッジの
間に来てほしい方がコミとかがこれが恥後
とかで立てばいいの
はいよろしくお願いしますよろしくお願い
します
と思います
gotoheaveninthe
morningPartyGalaxy
バージョンアルファ降板
フェニックスインフィニティカット
日本国民であり
我々から
書いてこう
セリフを覚えるみたいな
感じの人なんで今もこうホワイトボードに
書き写してるんですけどなるほどね
完成したから見てます
えバカだお前マジであのここが納豆巻き
ぬるぬるっしょ
ああなるほどねはいそういうこと
えあとでも僕がやばいって言えないのが
隣ですね
[音楽]
[拍手]
gotoheaveninthe
morningPartyVersion
[音楽]
ありがとう
はいというわけでそこそこ時間が経ちまし
た皆さんお疲れ様ですお疲れ様です
捗りました
[音楽]
モーニングパーティーギャラクシー
バージョンインフィニティドラゴニックス
です
[音楽]
[拍手]
全員合わせてお手を合わせて
いただきます
[音楽]
マスカットトリプルハニーハウス
が起こる理由はわからないおいおい
みんな静粛に
国王陛下がお通りです
[音楽]
日本国憲法を述べよ日本国民は政党に選挙
された
国会における代表者
代表者を通じて行動し
我らと我らの子孫のために
諸国民諸国民の
共和共和に今日は諸国民
諸国民と
諸国民族ありがとう
HIKAKINですいやー
クリアやったー
ここに手振りを入れていかに
YouTuberの自己紹介っぽくできる
か
もしますか
なんとなくやる人が見えた
ヤジと俺は
ソロパートの練習をもっとねしなきゃいけ
なくてあとみんなひたすら今の首を
しっかりと絡ま体になじませてくれました
はい
どうもー
レッツgotoheaveninthe
morningPartyGalaxy
バージョン
フェニックスインフィニティ
ドラゴニックスパスタ
コングラチュレーション
リングダイナソーセンタービコーズ売れ筋
プロジェクト
[拍手]
レッツgotoheaven
モーニングパーティーギャラクシー
バージョン
フェニックスインフィニティ
ドラゴニックス
[音楽]
Okお願いしますいきます
せーのどうもー
レッツgotoHeavenisthe
morningPartyGalaxy
バージョンアルファ
クソー
どうもー
レッツgotoheaveninthe
morningPartyGalaxy
バージョンアルファコガン
フェニックスインフィニティドラゴニック
フュージョンシステム
ヘブン
モーニングパーティーギャラクシー
バージョンアニファコナフィニックス
インフィニティドラゴンニックやばい飛ん
でる日本国憲は正当に占拠された国会に
おける代表者を代表者を通じて行動し
[拍手]
お
願いします
[拍手]
考えちゃダメだどうですか
[音楽]
[拍手]
よろしくお願いします
終了でございます
もう
脳がみんな疲れちゃってるから
後半かなりパフォーマンス落ちたと思うん
ですよこれ睡眠することによって1回今日
やったことを頭に定着させてその上で明日
さらにこうブラッシュアップを重ねて最高
の挨拶に辿り着く100%
頑張りましょうお疲れ
様
[拍手]
[音楽]
皆さんおはようございますおはようござい
ます
デイツーでございます
ごちゃごちゃしたしてた脳内が整理されて
燃えてるか不安な部分もあるけども割と
なんか定着してる感じのしてます今日も
よろしくお願いします
決まれば終わるからどうも
レッツゴーおはようございます
最初の像もおはよう伝説に書いてもいい
んだって
脳のスペースあるみんな大丈夫
[音楽]
いきます
せーのやつレッツゴートゥーヘブン
モーニングパーティーギャラクシー
バージョンアルファ交換
フェニックスインフィニティ
ドラゴニックス
ダイナソーセージ
クリニック初めこうだよし大丈夫
です
いただきます日本
[拍手]
国民は正当に請求された国会における代表
者を通じて行動し我々と我らの子孫のため
に諸国民と共和による生活を我が国全土に
渡って自由のもたらす計画を確保し政府の
行為によって再び戦争の参加が起こること
のないようにすることを決意しここに試験
が国民に依存することを宣言しこの憲法を
確定するお前が言うカスコンドームです
[音楽]
[拍手]
俺たちが世界一の自己紹介
YouTuber
[音楽]
ちょっとまたスクワットと動画撮る時は
この挨拶で始めます
コラボ期間3日撮りましょう
YouTuberってそんなしっかり挨拶
することないからこの形さえ覚えてれば
なんかまた再現できると思うんだよねはい
頑張ります